I left a Google review of the store I'm
a janitor at saying it's very clean mad
boy
what's up everyone my name is Peter pot
and today we're reviewing people that
are mad land yes I am wearing a beret
mad
[Applause]
mad at my daughter school it's medieval
day everyone else were distant princess
dresses or homemade Knight costumes this
kid
marches to his own drum plague doctor
mad like yo it's crazy
a young man land makes me proud been at
a wedding all day all my sister's
boyfriend has done is photoshopped
picture of my head looking messy and
send them to me what if his head is
actually that large that would be surely
man this is literally mad legs doing
something for no reason whatsoever
that's freaking mad land this makes me
want to go out and just like eat a
pickle for no reason that we every
someone cosplaying the actual Convention
Center that's mad man that is definitely
mad man very nice well done and who's to
say you cannot be a convention center if
you think about it it's mad labs that
break the norms and all the stigmas in
society we should all be thanking man
lives for us living in a society
thank you mad libs thank you I just
convinced my mate but the inside of a
cheese grain it's in fact a sick new
nightclub damn drippy his break where is
it
Shoreditch ex shall we go yes please
imagine being in that gap probably
freaking out I reckon you'd have a great
time Wow seriously sure ditch I'll go
I'm gonna say it now I'll freak a grader
I don't even care no that's true - man
like stepping it back stop low-key kinda
wanna go though guy named Joey tells
Ilham that Tesla autopilot chimes are
too loud and making up is baby
Tesla honors Joe's request and makes a
new setting that lowers alert volume
Tesla names it Joey Modi I always knew
it I always knew my man Elin was a man
land
let's put a smile on my face beautiful
Joe mode why why you named Joe mode but
not raised that might be ugly but I have
good ideas I wore green screen shirt to
picture day this is my ID card that is
30-man and like I we call it green
screen shirt you wore a green shirt you
dummy dumb Jesus Christ
some 0iq on this fella to story I'm
flying right now but through Wi-Fi Oh
through Wi-Fi that's epic and an app on
my phone
I'm honking the horn on my car back home
to annoy my family Wow
why car honk it can't be Marc he's in
airplane Oh God
Marc you're not allowed to Wi-Fi on
airplane dummy been short Piero a BOTS
reminding Ven Shapiro that he's short
every 30 minutes that is so evil that's
the meanest thing luckily I have no
insecurities that anyone can harass me
about your stupid and poor but i can
wear lifts live on Ben Shapiro live on
if we lose we get baptized if they lose
they go out drinking with us or they
played there by guru no my that hex
that's awesome
what is it the Mormon Church Mormon
Church comes knocking all right I got
you a deal buddy you and me uno the
stakes are high let's do the truly mad
lad truly badly it took nine years to
finish the joke I've seen this your
mom's so lazy
she took nine years to finish the
Richard I salute you my legs points I
wonder when Richard decided you know
what seven years
not long enough I think eight years yeah
that's when I'll do the punchline not
nine years you know someone else is
sitting on like nine years as well
they're like 40 years that's gonna be a
HEPA credit purse my legs they run
society deal with it Pay Pal support
hi I'm PayPal's virtual agent to get
started simply ask me a question I'm
still learning so if I can't help you
I'll direct you to it
researching Daniel I got scammed PayPal
support Lamar LMO it started off with
all the best food Twitter being savage
but now all these other corporations
wants to join in you'll call 911
I'm being robbed nine-one-one
replacement lmao you're poor so it
doesn't matter anyway good joke bought
brownies and for all my co-workers
wasn't because I was being nice but
because I heard they were doing random
drug tests and I didn't want to be so
unless they plan on firing the whole
staff force they better leave me the
freaking load damn
Leslie Davidson three mad mad I'm pretty
sure that's illegal but a man might
gotta do what a man life's gotta do to
run society
I bet Leslie it's the kind of guy that
would wear a beret michael reaves so I
heard add Fossum Dynamics is selling
their robotic dog platform I saw this
they're finally selling those creepy and
robots that looks like they could
they're gonna sneak into your house and
prick your mama
I never wanted something so bad in my
entire frickin life I can't stop
thinking of ideas for how to make it the
most terrifying thing that ever walked
the earth don't look too manly I just
want to know what year they'll make them
couple they already are spoilers they
already are again I know there's a
stigma to freak the Boston dynamic robot
but I will say it here to break that
stigma I will freak it I will and you
know what I'll go further I'll freak the
entire dog Boston dynamic corporation if
it's so what it takes if someone tried
to make me dig my own grave
I would say no what truly mad bad
they're going to kill me anyway
I'd love to die the way I live avoiding
manual labor to man like true I never
understood this either yeah they're
they're gonna shoot you anyway what are
they gonna do might as well shoot me
anyway they dig a grave okay just don't
shoot me okay I finished great now big
ah what he shot me I can
believe it like just say no gamers just
say no unless they want to shoot during
your knees because I think that hurts I
think getting shot in the knees and Plus
that would make digging the grave a lot
harder if you're laying on the ground
but you could still say no my dad if you
turn into the opposite sex for a day
what would you do get the load of my get
a load of mic and freeze it then when I
turn back try to get myself pregnant
with it and see what happens no here's
what you do before before you turn to
whamon you come a comma
put the bucket bucket then when your
woman you're like flip flop flip flop
flip flop you know and then you have bed
bed in your stomach and you turn back to
mam baby still stomach
well baby come out I'm not only man Ladd
I'm also big brain I said it
I'll put child inside my body I don't
care there's a stigma if you freaked up
in school you had to meet the teacher
after class freak out more and you had
to meet the principal in 2014 I use this
strategy to go all the way up the chain
of command and meet george w bush that
is i think that is absolute Madlen I was
expecting something about stealing the
Declaration of Independence but I guess
meeting george w bush it sounds pretty
lame actually i don't know why you would
do that public service announcement for
men boxers are not short you cannot wear
them outside don't tell us what to wear
teach girls not to stare
really oh yeah gamer girls then how come
you can wear bikini outside if it's not
underwear explosion the very unmasked
euler Australian comedian
thank you for specifying the very
unmasked allure Hamish Blake once won
the heavyweight category in the mr. New
York state bodybuilding competition
after entering as a joke as he was the
only competitor heavy enough to qualify
they called me a madman how do these
things exist then so confusing that's
right I am adjusting my AC while I'm
recording this video
mad flag she said she was thinking of
leaving me
I said think again there it is someone
did it
someone put bear bait inside of man
through mad lad
my teacher nail his students bone to the
wolf or using it in class 20 years ago
it's still there till this day my life I
like I no one else did it after that I
bet the teacher was like all right it
starts with a phone next up I'll put a
child up there okay
that was a little darker joke than I
meant to
I apologize vegan atheists this is a
Facebook group you have joined the
public group being an atheist to post
picture of Jesus eating a sandwich you
have been removed from the group sir
Facebook group for everything
vegan atheists captain Marvel's brie
Larson demand more diversity in
Hollywood so fans create a petition to
have her replace with the gay woman of
color wow she got trolled epically I
mean just don't take the role then come
on I saw captain Marvel's okay it was a
12-hour flight and I was gonna play
Minecraft but my computer wouldn't
charge on the goddamn outlet okay I had
nothing else to watch it was literally
all Captain Marvel he was like I was
living in fevered dream
it was awful I watched it and the worst
part
then they absolutely worst part of it
was that it wasn't even that bad oh god
ah don't watch it don't make my mistake
I got a two-way what I got a tattoo
beautify his leg on my arm
lawl where is the tattoo s MH reddit
Boosh read my name boy god of worship
gay whoo she's gay oh my god I'm so
proud my life Bravo boys up gay boy chef
cake just so we're clear bean cake
exactly okay everyone wins in this mean
eventually there will be so many human
beings that having an original thought
will be equivalent to winning the
lottery your appear to have submitted a
common or unwritten up haha as such it
has automatically we were
move one time I was late to practice and
my coach made me run laps my dad was the
coach in it mad my dad epic
Ethan paid you $7 she Portland nothing
great yeah your venom imbalance is now
seven bucks my friend I haven't talked
to in years just paid me back for sure
partly from seven years ago that's mad
that's absolutely man night we might be
mad legs but at least we pay back our
dues I did it y'all after a month of
mental preparation pain fear and
encouragement I finally worked up the
courage to tell my parents they're gay
god dammit I got you got me well played
my algebra teacher said that this was a
link to the test answers god damn it
just stop with a Rick actually how was
that a thing still how was that a thing
still it pisses me off but I think
that's the reason why it's still a thing
I just realized nevermind Swedish
madland until 1979 Sweden classified
homosexuality as a mental illness that
year activists took the classification
as an illness to its logical extent
Swedes called into cake - yeah can't
help it I'm just too much of a
homosexual that's true Matt Landry
fighting bigotry with Matt lathery
that's how it's done
breaking stigmas I hope everyone learned
something here today on man laddering if
you guys enjoyed this video
smash like and sub freaking scribe we
are trying to hit 200 million
subscribers can we hit it
[Applause]
check out merch
well you haven't tried to Bruce emulator
citizen e after 50 million outros fetch
my yeah don't just go it's still
relevant just download it